En este vídeo quiero hacer algunos problemas que tienen que ver con la pendiente de una recta,
también se conocen como problemas
de modelos de variación directa
Y la idea es que leamos el problema,
hagamos una gráfica
y después respondamos las preguntas que nos hacen.
Déjame empezar con este problema dice,
las regaderas ahorradoras de agua
tienen un flujo de 2.5 galones por minuto.
Entonces lo voy a poner por aquí,
2.5 galones...
galones por minuto.
Calcula cuánto tiempo llevará
llenar una tina de baño de 30 galones,
utilizando una de estas regaderas.
Muy bien,
entonces sería fantástico poder expresar
"g" la cantidad de galones
que se ha llenado la tina,
en función,
de la cantidad de minutos que dejamos correr el agua,
pero justo esto está dado por este flujo de acá,
es decir la cantidad de galones es igual a 2.5
galones por minuto...
multiplicado por la cantidad de minutos
que dejamos correr el agua.
Y listo este de aquí es nuestro modelo lineal
o nuestro modelo de variación directa,
que es un hombre es súper sofisticado,
pero que básicamente nos dice que
la cantidad de galones varía proporcionalmente
con respecto a los minutos con un factor de 2.5,
muy bien.
Entonces ya que tenemos esto de aquí vamos a graficar esta igualdad o bien esta relación.
¿Cómo le hacemos?
pues nos damos cuenta que esto de aquí
es en realidad una recta,
las rectas son del estilo
"y" igual a "mx" más "b"
"mx" más "b, cierto.
Aquí tenemos una cosa de ese estilo,
sólo que las letras están un poco cambiadas,
la "b" es 0 porque no estamos sumando nada,
la "y" es la "g",
la "x" es la "m",
porque es la variable independiente
y la "m" que es la pendiente,
es 2.5 galones por minuto.
muy bien, entonces con esto en mente, déjame hacer la gráfica aquí, pero antes déjame cambiar esta "g"
esta "g" a
cinco medios de galones por minuto...
galones por minuto...
por "m"
cinco medios y 2.5 es exactamente lo mismo, pero esto nos va a ayudar, para saber cuánto nos movemos en "x",
y cuánto nos movemos en "y".
Bueno,
entonces ahora sí voy a graficar,
con este color verde de aquí,
y entonces aquí voy a poner el eje de la variable independiente, que es la cantidad de minutos,
y acá el eje de la cantidad de galones,
aquí va a ser la cantidad de galones.
Y lo que nos dice esta pendiente
es que si avanzamos 2 en "x",
entonces avanzamos 5 en "y".
Bueno,
vamos a empezar aquí en el 0,
si tenemos 0 minutos,
entonces se han llenado 0 galones,
por lo tanto este punto, el origen,
está en la ecuación de la recta que nos interesa.
Ahora si avanzamos dos unidades en "x",
dos unidades hacia la derecha,
tenemos que avanzar 5 unidades hacia arriba,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
de modo que este punto también está,
en la línea que nos interesa.
Vamos a hacerlo una vez más,
avanzamos 2 a la derecha,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 hacia arriba
y podríamos hacer lo mismo hacia la izquierda,
avanzamos 2 hacia la izquierda,
pero ahora tenemos que avanzar,
5 hacia abajo,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
nos quedaría ese punto,
y de modo similar avanzando,
2 para acá y 5 para acá,
nos quedaría este punto de acá.
Entonces ahí tenemos 5 puntos de la línea.
Déjame unirlos,
sería de este punto a este punto de acá.
Ahí está,
bueno creo que quedó derechita,
y aquí tenemos la gráfica
de esta relación que tenemos por acá.
Ahora en realidad nada más nos interesa
lo que está en el primer cuadrante,
cuando los minutos son positivos
porque no nos gusta pensar en minutos negativos
o al menos no por el momento ¿vale?
Bueno, entonces tenemos que la región que nos interesa, es esta de este lado,
esta de acá ¿vale?
Bueno,
ahora sí vamos a responder la pregunta,
a ver si la gráfica nos sirve para algo.
Dice, calcula cuánto tiempo llevará llenar
una tina de baño de 30 galones,
entonces tendríamos que tener la gráfica hasta el 30,
pero aquí sólo la tenemos hasta 10 galones.
Entonces para no volver a hacerla,
mejor vamos a resolver este problema algebraicamente,
¿cómo le hacemos?
pues aquí tenemos la ecuación
que nos relaciona galones con minutos.
Y sabemos que la tina de baño es de 30 galones,
entonces voy a poner que "g" vale 30 galones,
y voy a poner todas las unidades
para que veas que todo cuadra al final,
entonces 30 galones va a ser igual,
a 5 medios de galones por minuto...
galones por minuto...
multiplicado por la cantidad de minutos
entonces,
¿qué tenemos que hacer ahora?
simplemente tenemos que dividir,
entre 5 galones
en entre 2 minutos, bueno,
entre 5 medios de galones por minuto,
de ambos lados,
para despejar "m" ¿vale?
entonces de este lado, voy a dividir entre
cinco medios de galones
por minuto,
y de este lado también,
entre 5 medios de galones por minuto....
galones por minuto...
y justo estoy haciendo esto
para que se cancele esto de acá,
para que la "m" quede despejada,
y vamos a ver qué nos queda,
lo voy a poner de este lado.
Entonces "m",
la cantidad de minutos que dejamos,
que necesitamos dejar correr el agua,
es igual a 30...
galones...
y aquí estamos dividiendo
entre 5 medios de galones por minuto,
pero eso es lo mismo que multiplicar por dos quintos,
de minuto por galón...
minuto por galón...
y entonces mira,
para empezar las unidades si cuadran.
Galones se van con galones
y aquí nos van a quedar minutos,
minutos, muy bien.
y de los números nos queda 30 entre 5 y 6.
30 entre 5 es 6 y
6 por 2 es 12,
entonces serían 12 minutos,
y por lo tanto esta de aquí es la respuesta.
Tenemos que dejar correr el agua,
correr el agua 12 minutos,
para que se llene la tina de baño.
Muy bien déjame pasar abajo
para resolver otro problema,
también es de llenado de cosas con agua
y dice lo siguiente,
dice, Wendy usa una manguera
para llenar su nueva alberca por primera vez.
Ella comienza a las 10 pm
y la deja toda la noche.
Voy pasando esta información,
voy a ponerle aquí hora.
Entonces,
comienza a las 10 pm...
10 pm...
y queremos ver cuánto se llena la alberca,
entonces le voy a poner aquí alberca,
la cantidad de albercas llenadas es 0,
vamos a ver qué otra información tenemos.
A las 6 p...
a las 6 am,
o sea se fue a dormir al día siguiente a las 6 am,
mide la profundidad
y calcula que la alberca está cuatro séptimos llena.
Ok, entonces aquí a las 6... a las 6 am
la alberca está cuatro séptimos llena.
Cuatro séptimos llena.
Y nos preguntan,
¿a qué hora se va a llenar su nueva alberca?
Muy bien, la idea es que otra vez,
vamos a plantear un modelo de variación directa.
Nombre sofisticado
pero es algo muy sencillo.
Simplemente vamos a decir que la cantidad de albercas que se llenan depende de una constante
multiplicada por el tiempo que ha transcurrido
¿vale?
por el tiempo que ha transcurrido...
Entonces,
sería muy bueno poder determinar esta constante,
porque a partir de ahí,
vamos a poder responder las preguntas.
¿Cómo le hacemos para determina esta constante?
Pues déjame poner aquí una tercera columna
que es el tiempo, voy a ponerle "t"
y vamos a pensar que a las 10 pm
no ha pasado nada de tiempo.
pero a las 6 am si pensamos todo en horas,
aquí le voy a poner que el tiempo está en horas,
a las 6 am y ya pasaron 8 horas...
8 horas...
Entonces aquí en la tabla ya tenemos información suficiente para determinar esta constante,
de la variación directa.
Suena muy complicado, pero es muy fácil,
simplemente vamos a copiar la información acá.
Entonces, ¿cómo le hacemos?
pues tenemos la información
de que la alberca está a cuatro séptimos llena,
le voy a poner así,
cuatro séptimos de alberca...
alberca...
Al tiempo "t" igual a 8,
entonces "k" por 8...
8 horas...
horas...
Entonces aquí ya podemos despejar "k",
para despejar "k" dividimos ambos lados
entre ocho horas
y ocho horas aquí para que se canele,
y aquí para ver que quedan ocho horas.
Y vamos a ver qué queda,
aquí esto se cancela
y por lo tanto "k",
la constante de variación directa,
es igual a 4 entre 8 es un medio
y aquí hay un 7 en el denominador,
entonces nos queda un catorceavo de alberca...
alberca...
por hora...
Muy bien estas unidades están medio raras ¿verdad?
alberca por hora, pero bueno,
esto está padre porque entonces
ya podemos poner a "a",
como un catorceavo...
un catorceavo,
de alberca por hora...
alberca por hora...
por la cantidad de tiempo que transcurre
y todo esto es en horas.
Pero lo que nosotros queremos es saber,
a qué hora se va a llenar su nueva alberca.
Es decir, queremos saber cuándo "a" es igual a 1,
cuando tenemos una alberca llena.
Entonces, vamos a ver cómo le haríamos.
Simplemente tenemos que ponerle aquí,
que "a" es igual a 1.
Entonces 1 sería igual a un catorceavo..
un catorceavo de albercas por hora,
multiplicado por el tiempo.
Bueno,
aquí 1 es una alberca verdad aquí debería ponerle "a",
entonces déjame ponerlo más bonito,
entonces...
una alberca es igual a un catorceavo
de albercas por hora multiplicado por el tiempo,
y entonces aquí podemos despejar el tiempo multiplicando por 14.
Entonces nos quedaría,
que el tiempo es igual a 14 horas.
Puedes checar que las unidades en efecto cuadran.
Muy bien entonces esto es aquí
es el tiempo después de las 10 pm,
que necesitamos para llenar la alberca,
pero eso todavía no nos dice,
a qué hora se va a llenar,
entonces hay que ser cuidadosos
de acordarnos pasar a la hora.
Entonces ¿cómo le hacemos?
pues una forma de pensarlo en la siguiente,
si empezamos a las 10 pm,
entonces a las 10 am,
van a haber pasado 12 horas,
a mí me gusta pensarlo así,
y entonces si necesitamos que pasen 14,
nos faltan otras 2,
y por lo tanto,
dentro de otras dos horas será el mediodía...
mediodía...
entonces la alberca de Wendy va a estar lista
al mediodía del día siguiente.
Muy bien, ya nada más para terminar,
como aquí tenemos espacio para hacer una gráfica,
déjame hacer la gráfica de esta relación,
¿vale?
Entonces acá voy a poner el eje "a"...
eje "a"...
no...aquí va a ser el eje "t",
la variable independiente va a ser "t"
y aquí va a ser la cantidad de albercas llenadas,
albercas llenas pues,
y vamos a poner algunos puntos,
cuando "t" es igual a 0 la cantidad de albercas es 0,
entonces tenemos este punto acá
y para que quepa en la gráfica,
o sea, tenemos que avanzar 14 unidades,
así que déjame marcar que éste mide 2,
y 4,
o sea cada marquita es de 2,
6, 8...
entonces sería 10, 12, 14...
y vamos a poner que esté,
en la escala vertical, si es de 1 en 1,
2, 3...
y de esta forma tendríamos este punto,
avanzamos 14 subimos 1,
también tendríamos este punto de acá
y por lo tanto la gráfica se vería algo así,
también sería una recta muy muy inclinada.
Ok, entonces con esto ya terminamos de resolver estos dos problemas de modelos de variación directa,
suena como algo complicado, pero simplemente tiene que ver con rectas y con sus pendientes y
con encontrar
la constante de proporcionalidad,
espero que esta gráfica no haya, pues,
resultado muy incómoda,
pero bueno, espero que te haya servido
todo esto que te platiqué,
nos vemos en los siguientes videos.